Todo parece impresionante en los Estados Unidos,
los años locos han vuelto. La economía crece,
hay pleno empleo, los salarios suben y se
están recortando los impuestos mientras los
ingresos del gobierno están en máximos históricos.
Sí, en los Estados Unidos todo parece ir
viento en popa y a toda vela.
Echemos sino un vistazo al S&P 500, el índice bursatil
más importante, el índice que recoge la
cotización de las 500 mayores empresas cotizadas
en los Estados Unidos.
Pues bien, llevamos 9 años viendo subidas
ininterrumpidas….
Creo, amigos, que no sería descabellado
decir que si echamos un vistazo al gráfico de este índice, nos recordaría mucho a la trayectoria
de vuelo de uno de los cohetes de Elon Musk.
¿No me creéis? Pues, atentos al dato. Desde
el año 2009, es decir, en menos de una década,
el S&P 500, incluyendo los dividendos, ha
tenido una rentabilidad de más del 400%
¿Sabéis cuánto supone esto? Pues para que
os hagáis una idea si hubiésemos invertido…
digamos... 10.000 dólares en el año 2009
en este índice, en el S&P 500 hoy tendríamos
50.000. ¿No está mal, verdad?
[Eso sí que es multiplicar los panes y los
peces. En los últimos años, amigos, ha sido
tan fácil ganar dinero en los mercados, que
casi que cualquier cuñado ha podido sentirse,
sí, como el mismísimo Gordon Geko.]
Pero, amigos, esperad un momento antes de
lanzar las campanas al vuelo… porque tengo
una pregunta, ¿Es todo realmente tan bonito
o acaso tiene la economía de Estados Unidos
una cara oculta, una cara menos glamurosa?
Pues, amigos, atentos.
LA OTRA CARA
En VisualPolitik solemos decir que las cosas
nunca son tan perfectas como parecen.
Sí, en estos momentos Estados Unidos es toda
una locomotora económica… una locomotora
de alta velocidad
Especialmente para todas
aquellas personas que han invertido, como
hemos visto, en las bolsas de Estados Unidos.
Sin embargo, amigos, la gran potencia norteamericana
tiene un problema… es adicta al crédito.
Tal cual como lo escucháis.
Empresas, familias, gobiernos… Gracias a
años y años de tipos de interés por los
suelos y de crédito casi ilimitado gracias
a las políticas de la Reserva Federal, prácticamente
todas las instituciones de este país devoran
deuda.
Sí, veréis. Tras la gran crisis de 2008,
los principales Bancos Centrales del mundo
decidieron poner en marcha una política que
podríamos describir, simplificar de esta
forma.
Si emitimos, es decir, si creamos más dinero,
es decir, lo que popularmente se conoce como
“imprimir más y más billetes”, y fijamos
tipos de interés muy bajos podemos lograr
dos objetivos:
(por un lado lograremos que los bancos presten
dinero a familias y empresas para que consuman
e inviertan y además las empresas que tengan
problemas podrán lograr financiación y no
tener así que cerrar. De esta forma la maquina
de la economía podría volver a ponerse en marcha.
Por otro lado, con todo este nuevo dinero,
también podemos financiar a los gobiernos,
de tal forma que no tengan que hacer recortes
severos del gasto y sigan consumiendo.)
Suena bien, ¿Verdad? Pues… esperad un momento
porque hay un pequeño problema…. ¿pequeño?
Enorme…
Veréis, esta receta, este plan… también
tiene consecuencias… porque no estamos hablando
sino de dopaje, de dopar la economía.
Y, amigos, cuando hablamos de dopaje económico, hablamos fundamentalmente
de dos cosas: de deuda y de inflación.
¿No me creéis? Pues atentos:
(En los últimos años Estados Unidos está
viviendo una época dorada. Se venden más
coches que nunca, el negocio inmobiliario
ha vuelto a despegar y todo tipo de productos
vuelan de los estantes de las tiendas.
Claro que, todas esas compras hay que pagarlas.
La deuda de las familias estadounidenses se
encuentra en máximos históricos y supera
los 13 billones de dólares, esto más de
40.000$ por ciudadano)
Pero, amigos, si pensáis que aquí termina
todo… ¿Sabéis qué? Estáis muy equivocados.
Si en vez de echar un vistazo a las familias
se lo echemos a las empresas, la situación
que nos encontramos es muy pero que muy parecida.
(Las empresas no financieras de los Estados
Unidos acumulan deudas de más de 8 billones
de dólares. Su nivel de apalancamiento hoy
es superior al de 2008 y la mayor parte del
incremento de toda esta deuda no ha ido a
equipos, fábricas ni nada parecido, sino
a recomprar acciones y pagar dividendos)
[Sí, amigos, lo sé, son cifras son tan altas
que cuesta no perderse]
Pero… un momento. Ni empresas ni familias
suponen el mayor problema… el mayor problema
de adicción lo tiene Washington, el Gobierno
Federal… y la administración Trump no se
salva.
Amigos, os hago una pregunta y no vale buscarla
en Google, ¿sabéis cuánto dinero se gasta
al año, cuánto cuesta el gobierno de Estados
Unidos? Atentos.
EL GOBIERNO
A comienzos de año, concretamente en febrero…
de 2018, el Departamento del Tesoro del gobierno
de los Estados Unidos publicó su informe
anual para 2017.
Es decir, un informe como el que presentan
anualmente las empresas que cotizan en bolsa,
donde dicen cuánto han gastado, cuánto han
ingresado, cuánto dinero deben o cuáles
son su previsiones. Todo, recogido de forma
clara en un único documento fácil de encontrar.
[Sí, creo que esta es una buena costumbre
del gobierno de los Estados Unidos]
Pues bien… amigos, el caso es que os doy
mi palabra, los números son casi de película
de miedo.
(En 2017, tan solo el gobierno federal, es
decir sin contar los estados y los municipios,
gastó o asumió compromisos de pago por valor
de 4,6 billones de dólares… Vamos, que
por sí mismo, el gobierno federal estaría
luchando por ser la tercera mayor economía
del planeta. ¿No está mal? ¡Menuda factura!)
Pero claro, como os podéis imaginar, como
los ingresos no dan para pagar todos los gastos…
pues el agujero que de verdad tuvo el gobierno
superó de largo el billón de dólares. Eso
sí que son unas pérdidas en toda regla.
Son más grandes que toda la economía australiana.
Para que os hagáis una idea, cada minuto
que pasa, ¡Cada minuto! el Gobierno de los
Estados Unidos pierde más de 2 millones de
dólares.
[Sí, creo que si el gobierno de Estados Unidos
fuera una empresa, sus accionistas no estarían
muy contentos]
Lo más sorprendente de todos estos datos,
amigos, es que para Estados Unidos 2017 no fue
un año de guerra, ni de crisis, ni de recesión…
ni nada por el estilo…. simplemente un año
normal… bueno que digo normal…. fue un año fabuloso, un año de crecimiento económico.
Pero vale, ¿Sabéis cuál es el resultado?
Pues… que la deuda del gobierno federal
asciende a esta formidable cifra que veis
en pantalla…
¡20 billones de dólares! Más de 60.000$
por estadounidense y, ojo, casi el triple,
más de 170.000 dólares por contribuyente.
Esto supone que la deuda de verdad del gobierno
de Estados Unidos, supera el 100% del PIB.
En la descripción os dejo, por cierto, el
enlace al documento del Tesoro.
Pero bien, tal vez sean este tipo de cosas las
que expliquen noticias como estas:
(“China amenaza: reducirá las compras de
deuda de EE UU”. Cinco Días.
“La deuda del gobierno de Estados Unidos
en manos chinas se reduce un 10% desde sus
máximos históricos”. Reuters)
Pero… ¿Sabéis qué? El Presidente Donald
Trump tiene un plan...
EL PLAN DEL PRESIDENTE
Últimamente parecía que demócratas y republicanos
eran incapaces de ponerse de acuerdo, prácticamente
en nada. Sin embargo… hay una forma de lograrlo:
romper la hucha y repartirse la pasta.
Y eso es precisamente lo que ha ocurrido.
En febrero, demócratas y republicanos han
alcanzado el mayor acuerdo bipartito en mucho
tiempo ¿Para qué? Pues para incrementar
el gasto público.
("Este acuerdo cumple con nuestro compromiso
de financiar plenamente nuestra defensa nacional,
no más tácticas y parches a corto plazo",
Paul Ryan, presidente de la Cámara de Representantes.)
Con este acuerdo, el gobierno de Estados Unidos
incrementará el gasto público en 150.000
millones de dólares cada año. ¡Más madera!
[Y eso que los republicanos se pasaron 8 años
criticando y criticando a Barack Obama por manirroto.
Ay… si es que el poder lo cambia todo. Porque
amigos, comprendamos a los políticos de Washington,
no me digáis que no os gustaría gastar a
manos llenas con un dinero que no es vuestro]
Pero… aquí no acaba todo… ¿Os acordáis
de la reforma fiscal de Trump que se acaba
de aprobar? Os hemos hablado de ella aquí
en Visualpolitik, en este vídeo.
Pues… como vimos, con la reforma fiscal
los ingresos del gobierno van a bajar bastante.
Así que una pregunta, si bajamos los ingresos
y subimos el gasto ¿Que tenemos?
¡Exactamente! Un déficit aún más grande.
(Tanto que se espera que en 2019 el déficit
del gobierno de los Estados Unidos se sitúe
entre el 5 y el 6% del PIB… Un déficit
enorme propio de un país en crisis. Porque,
vale, cuando hay una crisis todos podemos
entender que los gobiernos tengan agujeros
enormes en sus presupuestos: baja el empleo,
baja la recaudación, etcétera etcétera…
pero ¿Cuando todo va bien?)
[Sí, nos dijeron que Trump llegaba para poner
orden y poner fin al desenfreno de Washington..
pero parece que al final ha decidido apuntarse
a la fiesta por todo lo alto .]
Pero, por todo esto que hemos visto, cada
vez más expertos se preguntan ¿quién va
a comprar toda esta deuda?
Porque, claro, en los próximos años, el
Tesoro de Estados Unidos va a tener que emitir
billones y billones de deuda para pagar todo
este desajuste.
Y, en principio, los 3 mayores prestamistas
de Estados Unidos, esto es, la Reserva Federal,
China y Japón, ya no son compradores… así
que el resultado parece que puede ser este:
(“Esperamos que las tasas de interés en
aumento y un nivel de deuda en aumento conduzcan
a un aumento significativo del gasto de intereses.”Goldman Sachs.)
En fin amigos, así están las cosas. Esta
es la otra cara menos atractiva de los Estados Unidos.
Espero que con tanto número no os haya resultado
difícil seguir este vídeo, pero pensamos
que era importante contaros la otra cara,
la cara más oscura de la economía de Estados Unidos
para que podáis saber de verdad como
están las cosas y porque en Washington deberían
empezar a tomarse un poquito en serio este
problema.
Y no, imprimir billetes no es la solución.
Cada vez que se imprimen billetes se genera
más deuda e inflación. Y ocurren cosas como
esta:
(“El dólar cae a su nivel más bajo en
tres años” Reuters)
[Y ya hemos visto aquí en VisualPolitik, lo importante que es
tener una moneda fuerte, una moneda sólida.]
Pero ahora turno para ti, ¿Crees que los
políticos de Washington deberían recortar
el gasto público?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta. Si te ha resultado
interesante el vídeo no te olvides de darle
a like y suscribirte al canal si aun no lo
has hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.